okay so um he's gonna try to grab me at
some point or something to get it
and so this drill we're gonna we're
gonna go
and i'm gonna control his his grab okay
so let's look at how i can do this if
i'm on the inside i
want to pay attention to um
being below the elbow if i above his
elbow he's going to get a grab on me
okay so a lot of times you're doing your
uh cookie doggies and stuff like and
you're all over here
you get it and then he'll grab you you
see
um so you can do your cookie nugget
and then as you get closer to the wrist
away from the
elbows it's harder for him to grab you
see
um you can you get your fingers in there
you see and you you
just read the powder okay the other
thing you can do
is we go we're going and i'm going to
work on the back of the hand
so i have an id adhesion on the back of
the hand
right we're over here and i'll use the
left hand
and do the same projections through it
okay so
this isn't really at his point i'm not
just working on
on tilting him i'm working on him
not grabbing me not letting him get a
hold of me
okay he goes
and the cool part of this is that
when you have your adhesions right um
[Music]
he'll push on what he feels when he
feels the ground people push and
push back on that and so then they're
balanced and then you take a balance
they start using you for balance
and you can just get out of the way
okay so look for a combination of these
things so i'm here
and maybe i'm not quite getting him
out of the way okay so i'm doing all
of this stuff
mechanics for my draw
we're trying not to get cracked
okay so she goes i'm late
i'm late okay so she goes you're already
here
okay already here right
you have to you have to reach out for
the connection not reactionary
okay and she's going here
[Music]
you're not here you're not doing this
okay
i reach out contact okay so
stay stay where you are and run around
yourself around yourself it doesn't
matter
okay so when you reach out
is to contact contact you see try to
come in
contact try to pull away
so reach out content okay and then
yield so yield you see
not here not contact here can you see
again so yield and then when you
heal because you shoot harder you see
themselves
up
[Music]
so yield
non-contest project
and it's just it's just really quick
because i don't need a great distance
that was it okay
it would be like go racing over here
she's still going the other way when i'm
racing you see
but
real okay so she goes and
i'm going to uh you see how i keep
in here so feel your weight on me
so there's a place where you don't where
where i'm going around your enemy
okay so i'm going to go around i'm not
going to push you
i already hear them so
you'll find it
[Music]
there's a place in
oh that's not it
and it's to that okay
you see it's not
so this goes that's not
it i find where i can move
[Music]
ah okay try that
no projection so i'm not going my
deviation out of here it's right real
close
super close
so this this that that that maneuver
was this but you're doing it out here
so we're right here and you have to
relax because if you do tension
you're gonna he's gonna get a ledge on
you you see
so you have to release the tension
release the tension
[Music]
i'm here like this and i feel like i'm
i'm relaxed but you have tension
in your legs do you see and it's enough
to cause the
uh the leverage that he needs okay
so my whole body my whole body
very relaxed okay so
tension is bad okay tension is a product
of the ego tripartite and its
dichotomous world view
you threatening to me so i have to
overpower you it kicks my will to power
into effect
and i get i gotta overpower you okay
um remember that the other side of the
ego tripartite is that preferential
behavioral pattern
okay so i prefer this i prefer me
throwing you rather than you grabbing me
so
you have a desire right and this is why
desires problematize where the mystic is
because it's based in dichotomy which is
based in ego
attachment which is will to power and
the delusion that i
overpower you okay so we go back to the
first drill
and he goes i'm doing the same thing
with my with my
arms okay um
but just remember that as you go and you
go here
the desire to throw him is
attention okay so as you're going it's
just very loose
it does his job if i'm doing my my
cloaking projection
i don't need to launch him you see
i just giving
[Music]
the point is
don't start pushing back on him either
okay
you got to watch the desire to
win against him it'll make you tense and
then you can't do ikea okay
all right try it again